Philip Howard author of the death of
common sense when was the first time you
thought this might be a book I was about
three and a half years ago when I was
walking around on the Lower East Side
Manhattan I was talking to an older lady
and in public housing and she was
telling me a story what was his dark
well the story was she was describing
her problems in getting her refrigerator
fixed in public housing and what she
said was she'd call up a bureaucrat who
said no I don't have responsibility go
to someone else went to the second then
she went to the third bureaucrat who
then referred her back to the first
bureaucrat her face as she was telling
the story twisted in frustration she was
humiliated by this experience of no one
really honestly responding to her
problem the interesting thing to me in
the story was aight spent the morning
with the CEO of a major company
describing his effort to work on a jobs
program with the government and as he
was telling the story he couldn't even
get them to respond to the issues and
the questions and as he told the story
his face had twisted in frustration he
gets so excited about it and that
afternoon as the lady was telling me the
story I realized that that she and the
CEO were basically the same person and
that something had gone wrong that
wasn't rich versus poor it wasn't
whether government had a role or not it
was something about the way government
worked you come to this with political
label I mean a Europe your Republican or
Democrat well I'm a registered Democrat
but I don't I don't go to bed dreaming
about it are you a liberal or
conservative I always thought I was
liberal but I consider myself pretty
much in the center and I tried to make
the book interdenominational if you will
and both sides are responding to it so
so I think it's working at one point in
the book he refer to progressive you use
that word progressive we would that be
you I mean that in a historical sense i
mean that in a a turn of the century
historical sense of the word three and a
half years ago what were you doing to
for a living uh what i do now which is i
work at a corporate law firm
I started what kind of law we do special
projects for large business institutions
this book is eighteen dollars and 202
pages and among other things I just
picked this up this is a cover of US
News and it's the death of common sense
in America you're on all the television
networks what is it about this book it's
gotten people's interest I think well
what I tried to do is create a
vocabulary for people to respond to
public problems that they didn't have
now when people confront government they
they're told where the rule requires
this so you have to do it even though
everyone knows it makes no sense or
commonly in America someone says give me
my rights we cringe and you know what do
we do about someone's rights and what I
explained to the book is those ideas of
law didn't even exist 35 years ago the
new version of rights are not any kind
of right that our founders fought for
and created a government over and the
idea that law should be an instruction
manual telling us exactly how high our
railing should be and how many square
feet the nursery school is is not
anything that existed in our country
when I was growing up it's a brand new
invention and it doesn't work your
father was a minister yes where Eastern
Kentucky mainly where did you grow up I
started out in Tifton Georgia little
southern town north of the florida
border and moved to Eastern Kentucky
when I was seven what town in eastern
kentucky whitesburg kentucky a
coal-mining town of about 1,300
initially and then mount sterling
Kentucky which is a farm town on the
border of the mountains and the
bluegrass kind of a minister why is he
still liable yep he's still alive is a
is 80-year just turned 84 horsy live he
lives in knoxville tennessee now and
what kind of minister was he was a
Presbyterian minister what impact did
that have on your life a huge how I had
a very privileged upbringing well I
spent my childhood going around to work
camps in southern Georgia coal mines
do trailing along my father as he did
social work that was I think important
and developing my values in structures
and and I think it's important it helps
me understand people of different
economic backgrounds and different goals
perhaps better than most people what
year were you born 48 so growing up in
the south and the 1950s a little bit by
growing up in another century why well
there wasn't much money everybody still
talked about their relatives in the
Civil War that's how they got their
character it was very different than it
is that how long you live in New York
City I moved to New York initially after
college in 1970 and then I would law
school and came back in 74 and so I've
lived in New York now for 20 20 some
years did you think when you wrote this
book that you'd get this kind of
attention that was my hope but did you
think you would I didn't have any
expectation of that I had identified a
problem I had a question to answer which
is why everyone hated government and why
it could never do anything the homeless
problem has been with us for 15 years
virtually without effect without any
effective response and while it's a
complex problem it's not as complicated
as as we've made it I didn't understand
why why for example someone like Mother
Teresa we tried to build a homeless
shelter in the Bronx why why a system of
law would require her to put in an
elevator she would never use forcing her
or causing her to abandon the project
have you had any discussions with people
sitting across the table from you that
say this is a bunch of hooey there was
somebody taking you on on your basic
theory here not really no I mean lawyers
there are interest groups who will not
like this group might like this book I
mean everyone who has gotten rights in
the last few decades like the disabled
or special education right open-ended
mandates
they won't like the book bureaucrats
won't like the book because because what
I talk about is completely inconsistent
with the way they live their lives and
lawyers may not like the book toilets on
the street in New York City a classic
example of why the technique of rights
are nothing that a democracy should use
to try to balance competing interests if
you pass a law which the disabled laws
are giving the disabled an absolute
right to equal access to any public
facility what it means is that they have
essentially a credit card to force
anybody to do anything that doesn't
comport with this open and demanding so
when New York wanted to put in public
toilets which are desperately needed in
New York City and they found a unit
which was small enough to fit on the
crowded sidewalks the disabled came in
and said sorry wheelchairs don't fit in
them therefore you can't do them and so
new york city still has no public
toilets because a point two percent or
whatever it is of the population there
in wheelchairs couldn't use them and the
question is not whether they were
accommodated or not the question mean
for example people in wheelchairs could
have been accommodated in nearby
buildings when restaurants or the like
it's just a question of their desire to
be mainstreamed and do everything
exactly the same way as everyone else
which is by the way a perfectly
reasonable goal as a kind of a general
proposition but when you make it a right
you're never able to balance the
interest when it doesn't make sense and
it didn't make sense to ban public
toilets for 98.2 whatever it is ninety
nine point eight percent of the
population was there an experiment
though yeah there was an experiment for
a few months in which they compromised
by having one small toilet next to one
disabled toilet the disabled toilet you
know this could only be on a very wide
sidewalk and the disabled toilets at the
end of the experiment had been virtually
unused because
the fact of the matter is there are very
few people in wheelchairs compared to
the rest of the population you also tell
a story about a man in Rhode Island
right was injured back in 1986 right I
mean what happens with people when they
when they have a right or mid some
people is that they become zealots and
this man has brought over 2000 lawsuits
he brought a lawsuit to change to stop a
school dance where his daughter went
because he couldn't get into the to the
facility because it didn't have the
appropriate ramps and so it had to move
where the dance was but what's happened
as a result of them the institutions of
our country things like schools have
been so weighed down by legal
requirements disabled laws only being
perhaps the smallest of them that things
like elementary schools rebuilding
toilets and showers that are perfectly
functional for people in wheelchairs who
may not even exist in that age group in
that town it just doesn't just doesn't
make sense it would you feel differently
I think if you edit the right around a
wheelchair all day no I would not least
I hope I would not have never have I
mean I so I can't have you ever talked
to anybody that sure I friends in
wheelchairs and do they agree with you
uh no they don't they the plight of
someone in a wheelchair is a plight of
daily indignities as you try to get from
place to place where a six-inch curb is
might as well be a high wall and for
that reason I think having disabled
access laws is a very good thing my
gripe is not with regulation as such
it's how we do it and what's happened in
America is that we've created these
techniques of regulation that make it so
that so that well Americans are being
driven crazy look at the last election
across the board rights only being one
of those new techniques
it's again everything democracy is not
about rights rights or freedoms and the
Bill of Rights democracy is about
compromise and when when government
hands out and open-ended right to
someone anyone it loses its capacity to
compromise or balance the situation as
it as it occurs in the back you say you
use two pseudonyms Jane O'Reilly and
John Nesbitt well why did you pick those
two names and what do they represent the
names are completely arbitrary and and
they didn't represent anything they're
just people who didn't want to use their
name and what were the stories behind it
to him well it one's that one's a right
story and one is a nursery school story
in Boston the regulations for nursery
schools require this enormous checklist
of items that inspectors will come in
periodically make sure you have for
example a separate set of clothing for
for every child in case they soil their
clothing well that happens to take up a
lot of room for the 30 kids in this
particular nursery school and so the
person runs the nursery school why can't
I just keep four or five sets on hand
and the parents can return them she got
a citation for having I forget what the
rule was that it broke but for breaking
the rule because there was a toy
refrigerator that wasn't bolted to the
wall now this toy refrigerator never
caused the problem but the inspectors
you know citing some rule about unstable
toys or something had given her a ticket
for that and other time she got a ticket
because the joy dishwashing liquid was
on the counter of the kitchen be used
for bubble blowing and making water they
good for blowing bubbles was too close
to the edge and a child might have
reached for it now you can argue I
suppose the other side of each of those
points but they're not very important to
the nursery school what's important for
the nursery school from the government
standpoint
is it a clean professional loving place
that nurtures the children those however
are human judgments no one goes to her
nursery school and checks on how
professional and loving it is what they
do is they give tickets for whether the
toy refrigerator is bolted to the wall
or not that kind of regulation doesn't
make sense OSHA which is the worker
safety law the federal worker safety law
is like a parody of inept government
because of what it has is 4,000 rules of
things that a rule writer can make
objective like how high the railing is
putting a poisonous sign above sand or
anything else that conceivably might be
poisonous even though they're not 99
percent of the time and they go around
giving tickets for the off there's an
oil rag you get a ticket because you had
an oil rag or you didn't fill out this
form properly you get a ticket of course
none of those things have much do
anything to do with safety and in fact
after 20 years and billions of dollars
spent by industry osha's had no effect
or almost no effect on worker safety
what has an effect on worker safety are
human attitudes training supervision
management things you can't write down
in a rule in one brick factory I visited
in Pennsylvania did you lived through
OSHA for 18 years or so and then they
got a new manager and he decided the
accidents were too high and they cost
too much money he started out giving out
prizes like tool kits at the end of the
quarter if a worker didn't have a lost
work day the accident rate declined by
75 percent in one year because they were
using human incentives and looking at
the human factor of safety not all these
objective factors you say that OSHA the
Occupational Health and Safety
Administration has had and that law has
had no impact no impact but how do you
know people argue that I mean you can
argue either way the Brookings study for
example there was a wonderful book that
called rights at work that came out
a couple of years ago by Brookings and
what you do is you compare of accident
rates and death rates and the accident
rates and the death rates are somewhat
different than they were 20 years ago
ones up a little and ones down a little
but basically the numbers are the same
who wrote the Occupational Health and
Safety Act well Congress wrote the AI
mean then what a party or what
politician what side would you know all
of us came out of the not all this much
of the regulation federal regulation
came out of the great society including
worker safety laws and there is a story
about worker safety laws which i think
is I'm not sure in the book or not
actually it was at one point but most
people most Americans and I would argue
very strongly in favor of worker safety
laws to all the sweatshops the horrible
child labor abuses of the the turn of
the century the Lincoln Steffens exposed
abuses they occurred because there were
no laws and so everyone quickly slipped
down to the level of the greediest
manufacturer because whoever the
mean-spirited person was was working
people literally to death was getting a
competitive advantage so everybody else
it had to even if they were perfectly
nice people sank down to that level so I
believe that you need regulation for for
worker safety the question is how you do
it and the idea is this kind of version
of central planning which is we're going
to it's as if Norman Rockwell were put
in one of these office buildings and and
they scratch their heads and they say
gee what would a perfect factory would
look like you know the railing should be
42 inches high let's make that a
standard and they go through this time
after time whenever there's an accident
let's write another rule for that one so
they have these four thousand rules
people don't even know the rules they're
too many to know the inspectors don't
know the rules no one complies with the
rules because there are too many to
comply with the the warnings they now
have warnings for over 600,000 products
I saw the other day on the bulletin
board of a museum
and OSHA warning prominently displayed
on the bulletin board they used to be
postcards and pictures of kids and stuff
against eating the toner of the
photocopier now that is something those
people needed I mean this it also
Admiral remedies for what you do if you
do eat the tone of the photocopier yeah
we don't need to be warned against the
towing eating the toner or the
photocopier we are first of all have
more important things to warn against or
it's more important just to live life
and yet we've got this absurd system of
worker safety that doesn't really help
what's the John Nesbitt's door the
Nesbitt story is more of a right story
it's a combination story John Nesbitt
was an assistant united states attorney
not his real name not his real name who
but the person was who who's boss had a
terrible secretary he couldn't get rid
of her because it's a federal employee
and this is whole bureaucracy about
federal employee and his boss couldn't
take her anymore so he kicked her down
to John Nesbitt and his colleague she
did it never showed up for work on time
did a terrible job had a terrible
attitude they did what you have to do
and under the rules of the bureaucracy
for federal employees and started making
a log of all of the things she did wrong
finally finally day yeah they had a
complaint you she didn't show up for
work for a week or something and one
thing after another after 18 months they
finally got the most severe sanction
they could which was a serious downgrade
which meant that she didn't get his big
arrays and she otherwise would have
gotten otherwise no effect so they're
working along another person in the
office has an emergency a woman lawyer
has an emergency hearing coming up and
she and this secretary is is given the
job typing it up woman comes by there's
no she hasn't doing it work she's
talking on the telephone and these
papers due in court right away so she
says please hurry this this is due
doesn't do anything meanwhile this lady
comes back into the secretary comes back
into the into the office says to the
woman lawyer if you ever talk to me that
way
again I'm going to kick your ass the
woman lawyer outraged immediately went
to the supervisor and said that person
should be should be fired and one thing
led to another that was impossible to do
because he had so many sort of built-in
incrustations of rights and rules she
hired a lawyer sued for discrimination
because the secretary sued for
discrimination because they were trying
to relieve her job eventually they
resolved it by putting her on suspension
for nine months on full pay and that was
and of course the joke around the office
was misconduct gets you a paid vacation
somebody else was interviewing for a job
they ran into her at another office
where she was working at another job
while getting full pay from the from the
federal government the story what the
story illustrates among other things is
that you can't have in human relations
you can't rigidify them there is such a
way to to such an extent that people are
no longer responsible and what's
happened throughout government is that
we have a system basically designed to
avoid responsibility go back to the
three and a half years ago where you say
was it the Lower East Side your aunt
done did you know this woman on the
street oh okay and then why did you have
the kind i was working in a local
political campaign what kind of politics
what kind of is a city council race it
was a local race and you were playing
what role in there i was a candidate for
this part time job of City Council of
him in New York City uh-huh I think well
what had happened is it redone the City
Council and they said we want citizens
to come out and occupy this post we're
going to make it more important and make
it a serious job so I thought as a good
citizen I would go and try to do it did
you win I did not what party were you
running Democratic it was the only party
and a district is for the Manhattan
borough or it was no it's just for a
small section of lower men why did you
lose you know they didn't vote for me as
much as they voted for the other people
and three and a half years ago you said
I want to write a book no I well I
started looking into the quest
so what is it that's wrong why are why
are things not working and how how did
you get to that first step where you
know here we are random house 202 pages
later and it took me in a year and a
half to come up with a basic idea and I
wrote an essay I handed it around to a
few people I gave it to Arthur
Schlesinger I gave it to a few other
smart people who I know and they told me
they thought I was onto something I mean
a month but what I was saying and is the
less it was very radical I was saying
among other things that law shouldn't be
precise that law had to leave room for
people to use their judgment and if it
didn't leave room for people to use
their judgment it just became a form of
central planning and that we had lost
sight of the way all our legal
institutions had worked for centuries I
mean that the Constitution is a set of
general principles which change which we
adjust as times change and our Mora is
changed and the common law which
operates on principles like the
reasonable person standard always leaves
room to adjust for the circumstances so
you did an essay you pass it off to
Arthur Schlesinger and then one and then
some people heard about and picked up on
it before I knew it I was in pari Evans
office at random house and he was saying
you ought to write a book about this you
say some people this these connections
you have where they were friends i was
talking about it and you know among
friends so you're in Harry Evans office
is the top guy at random right and how
does he you know he says it sounds like
a good book we should make a book out of
it and so I say what a great idea
figured it out i'm sure it'll only take
me six months of part-time work to do
this and did you know him before no and
did they give you a big advance they
gave me in advance it almost paid for
the first i pay for more than the first
year of research help but it didn't you
know it's not it's not a way to make a
living as you know you've got lots of
anecdotes in here right what would you
say is the main source of your anecdotes
it's about half and half newspapers and
magazines and
and interviews I mean they're wonderful
they're there's just so many sort of
wonderful stories I mean I three times
as many stories as I had in the book but
but one of the principal points of the
book is the idea that this idea that the
law can't be too precise and so she take
environmental law for example there's a
story of the Amoco refinery in Virginia
where amoco spent 31 million dollars to
catch the benzene at the smokestack but
there was almost no benzene at that
smokestack it turned out all the benzene
was escaping at the loading dock but
there is no rule at for catching benzene
at the loading dock so it didn't get
caught in amoco spent 31 million dollars
that's the story of American law if you
write something in advance some rural
writer it will never fit the
circumstance just as if you if you
swerve your car and you cause an
accident what happens is that you're
usually liable if you swerve your car
because you're avoiding a child you
shouldn't be liable words on a page
can't take those circumstances into
account life is too complex and things
like worker safety or even more so
environmental law are so complicated
that our effort to lay it all out in
advance and rules and regulations has
created the nightmare that's driving
everyone crazy this is your dedication
page yes Olivia Charlotte lily and
Alexander and for Alexandra who are they
they are the first for our children and
the last one is spouse and how old are
the children the children are in
descending order 16 12 ate and ate and
what do they think of the spouse is 102
and she'll love that what do they think
of this book and all the publicity are
getting um well I think they're pleased
by the mean they saw me slaving away for
however long it took the you know for
several years to write it
so they're there please but they sort of
take life and stride you know they don't
I think they don't think it's the
biggest deal in the world when did you
decide you had a 202 page book instead
of a 500 feet oh I knew I never had a
500 page book the question is whether I
would get the the 200 page book out I
actually completely scrapped what I've
written I've tried completely written
most of it and started all over again
when did you write it by the way I mean
you're a lawyer you had to practice law
right I took weekend's nights and then I
took time off early in 1994 I basically
took two and a half months off where I
did nothing but but right day and night
did you get on the phone to these people
yourself and interview them sometimes
and I had one full-time researcher they
buried but they want one full-time
researcher for over two years and
several part-time researchers had
wonderful to intellectual historians at
clairmont that were great at CalPERS in
California who were who are very
important in getting historical and
philosophical sources for me what's the
claremont connection a friend of a
friend students out there are they
professors PhD candidates so you're
working with folks in the west coast
you're practicing law in Manhattan right
and then I have full time research
assistant talking to talking to doing
interviews and talking to people and
following up but a lot of it I did
myself i drove down to a brick factory
in Pennsylvania and in three hours got
enough stories to fill up a book I mean
you can these stories are not hard to
come by this is the story of America I
mean if this book does well which I hope
it does and if it has an impact which I
hope it does it's because the people
reading it will will recognize all these
stories I mean is this your first book
yes what's the hardest part of all this
by the way there were two very hard
parts of it actually the first the the
hardest part was getting beyond the
conventions of modern America it took me
sick for six months I didn't sleep
at the end of 1992 because I knew I was
on to something I couldn't quite figure
it out getting to the idea that law
shouldn't be precise and the idea that
we had replaced responsibility which is
the whole basis of our Republic our
political systems responsibility we
replaced that with process and the
notion that rights instead of being the
thing that we think they are which is
this hallowed wonderful the most
American tradition were in fact
anti-american and the opposite of the
rights that our founders had fought for
took getting through a number of
psychological hurdles it seems so
obvious than me now that I'm now that
I've written the book and obvious I
think that most people who read it but
it wasn't obvious to me several years
ago it was very hard you quote a fella
but image on tuck a former
Undersecretary of the Department of
Energy as saying it's been 30 years
since I felt anyone has been excited
about working in government now you can
hear folks sitting out there that aren't
liberal aren't Democrat are
conservatives saying the Liberal
Democrats 30 years ago started this
process that now they're complaining
about explain how this all works 30
years later where you're upset about
what the results are one of the many
ironies here is that the Conservatives
are just too much to blame as the
liberals and I think one of the great
misinterpretations of modern politics
which is happening in capitol hill as we
speak is that the battle is between
government or no government that's what
Reagan said and that's what Gingrich is
saying I really don't think that's the
battle if you look at polls of Americans
they want environmental regulation I
don't know anybody who doesn't want
environmental regulation they want
worker safety laws they want most of the
regulatory services question is how it
works and 30 years ago a little over 30
years ago they started changing the way
they wrote law but it wasn't the
Liberals who words behind it alone the
Conservatives are so desperately afraid
of anyone in government having any
discretion
that they want to tie it all down button
it up so that there's no possible chance
for anyone to use their judgment because
they sell fear government officials the
Liberals so fear people being regulated
think that businesses are going to pay
off the government officials going to
use their economic might to get away
with murder that they want to button it
up and tie it down so they can never
squirm out of the regulation the one
place where both the Liberals and the
Conservatives agree is the one place
where government fails which is that
everything has to be laid out in advance
that law will be an instruction manual
telling us how to live our lives where
did you go to school I went to starting
wed college I went to Yale College where
get your law degree I went to the
University of Virginia law school and
along the way I mean the reason I bring
us up as I wrote down the different
justices and judges that you quote in
here and i'll just quickly go over
Charles Evans Hughes William Brennan
earl warren benjamin cardozo Felix
Frankfurter Antonin Scalia Oliver
Wendell Holmes jr. and Jay skelly right
David Bazelon and then a lot of other
folks but of all of those it seemed that
I saw benjamin cardozo the most and he's
the one I'm in law man why because
because law and it's actually no
different now than it was in Roman times
law the complex relationship between
guidelines and flexibility is something
that human beings have been struggling
with with law for as long as there's
been civilization these issues have all
been thought about before benjamin
cardozo at the end of a period beginning
at the turn of the century when people
said we thought we could turn law into a
science had a series of lectures at Yale
were brilliant I encourage everybody to
read them one call the nature of the
judicial process where he says basically
life can't be like a perfect light law
can't be like a perfect letter writing
God you can't create the certainty that
isn't available elsewhere in life
we have to eventually we can use
guidelines and and rules to an extent
but we always have to fall back on our
judgment and community mores and law
can't work in any other way and these
people these incredibly brilliant and
wise people have been largely forgotten
they understood the problem that the
people who wrote our laws in the last
three or four decades didn't understand
they just made the same mistake it's
some people at the turn of the century
main thinking they could make law into a
science did you study people like
benjamin cardozo at the University
Virginia a little bit most of this to be
fair I wasn't much of a student I made I
always successfully I was always at the
very bottom of the very top of the class
and I got that way not by being a great
student and a learning sense most of
these things I read a really read
closely for purposes of this book that's
what I wanted to ask you because you
also quote Woodrow Wilson before he
became president right and Jim Landis
these are all discoveries I mean I knew
who many of these people were but they
were discoveries the year and a half
before I tried to write the book that's
who I was reading I said well who who
can comment on these things and I just
reading all our red Hayek I read Woodrow
Wilson Cardozo homes there's a wonderful
homes compendium talk about the son of
all our 10 homes no I'm talking about
the one we know about the the Justice
the just the father was also a writer I
insanely right but I'm talking about the
Supreme Court justice the one whose
career again people have forgotten most
of this Oliver Wendell Holmes jr. was a
lieutenant in the Battle of Antietam and
was wounded and was still in the supreme
court in 1932 it's extraordinary career
and his letters his letters and speeches
are a compilation of it was put together
by Judge Richard Posner a couple of
years ago called the essential homes a
wonderful book sort of expressing the
the humor and intelligence of of a great
American and great thinker you also
quote bus less hovel
and Max baber socialist from Germany and
you said Friedrich Hayek from Austria
and Tocqueville now I've got to ask you
about toe clubbing every book I picked
up on this show almost in the last I
don't know how many months has quotes
from taupe-y this mark guy but when were
you first in a distant I never read
democracy in america from cover to cover
closely until i got interested in this
subject and there is much in there and
it's a joy to read was he a liberal or
conservative I don't know I think he's
conservative in many ways but I think
he's a humanist I think the important
thing about all the people who use cited
not all of them actually some of those
people are villains I cite them as
villains rather than who's your villain
there are a number of what I would call
villains Charles rice was a professor at
Yale i think is a villain he gets a lot
of attention in your book yeah he does
the idea it was actually a nice utopian
idea and everybody at yale in the 60s
including myself fell for it it just
didn't happen to work his idea basically
being that every dealing with government
should be like a property right and due
process should should the protections of
due process you'd apply even to the most
incidental government encounters a
teachers with students contractors with
with bureaucrats it's proved to have to
be like an infection let me design her
up to he had a article called property
rights or a book a kind of wonderfully
written article called the new property
book and in 1963 when were you at Yale I
was at Yale from 66 to 70 did you know
Charles right no is he still a lot yes
he's still a professor here and you say
he had a tremendous impact Oh a
tremendous impact normally influential
the Supreme Court fell right for it so
one article every day wasn't he then he
had to follow up article he wrote a book
called the greening of America get a
number of his a very prolific and
brilliant writers this happens to be
wrong who picked him up though I mean
who used his work this was all look at
the context everybody did it was every
quote much is a function of the times in
which it happens just as we are you know
in the middle of some perhaps a Gingrich
revolution of a like we were then at the
at the crest of a civil rights movement
where people were reexamining the whole
idea of authority and we had all these
abuses of southern governors we were we
had just discovered that rivers were so
dirty that they were catching on fire
and water supplies were threatened there
were all these things that had been
neglected and in justices that hadn't
even been touched that we were
discovering at the time that Charles
rice tried writing his articles it was
in that context that he flowed forth
with a new theory that would prevent
these things from ever happening again
the problem was it dehumanized
government and it essentially tried to
do away with the idea of authority which
in the context of a teacher trying to
run a classroom is a very dangerous
thing to do and has resulted in what we
have to do to today which are inner city
schools which are completely out of
control in your bio in the back they
have you involved or you are involved in
a lot of things in New York City
including an officer of the New York
City Industrial Development Agency right
what is that it's a it's a corporate
it's just a way to try to get businesses
to stay in New York it's it's not the
most important government agency around
how about the Municipal Art Society that
is pretty important it's a it's a it's a
civic group and it's actually enormously
influential at civic group a very good
and active board concerned the land use
issues and I used to be Council and now
I'm a vice president and he it would led
the fight to save Grand Central Station
st. Bartholomew's Church create the
years ago it's a hundred years old was
the principal movers behind the first
zoning code in New York we brought a
lawsuit very unusual for conservative
organized
mission which it's filled the members of
the board or heads of corporations and
lawyers such to stop for example the
building that was going to be built on
columbus circle that was going to cast a
shadow on Central Park this is ammar
mehrzad mortimer zuckerman now my patron
put me on the cover of his magazine but
at the time I brought a lawsuit and
stopped his building from being built
and that's the magazine we just talked
about right right and we're gonna shot
him in here you see that there's your
way do you know him sure I went around
debating him at the time of the at the
time of he was trying to put the
building up so you were against him
absolutely why did he put you on the
cover and put your you put an excerpt in
your magnet and his amazing I think he
liked the book you also headed a zoning
for a new york community board right
very a wonderful experience man new york
divided into community boards which are
public consistent of forty members each
one approximately that were appointed
and then they elect their own officers
within them and they hold public
hearings and they make recommendations
on matters of public significance and
for a number of years as a young lawyer
i ran the zoning part of that community
board which was midtown manhattan and so
essentially running the zoning board
from midtown Manhattan it was very
interesting many fights wonderful
fighting is Harry Helmsley who was going
to threaten to bulldoze the tudor city
parks in this development he owned but
bulldozers next to them and scaring all
the residents half to death and unless
the city gave him a playground that
wasn't any great shakes but it was a
public playground across from the UN
which was nearby for him he put a
building on and these kids kept coming
to the community board I was sharing his
hearing who ran a high school kids who
ran a roller hockey league for younger
children and one of the kids his name is
John Caulfield had a terrible stutter
and he would get up there were three
minutes for speakers to speak at the
public part of the hearing he would get
up and speak and he couldn't even get
his name out basically
in the three minutes and it was torture
there he was in front of in any given
night a hundred and member 150 or 200
members of the public plus the community
board members stuttering away trying to
say why the playground was important and
so moved me and everybody else that we
decided that we would figure out do
whatever we could to stop a city from
swapping this playground for the tudor
city parks and if necessary to call his
bluff if he want to direct the value of
his own development them and that's a
bad thing for a person to do so be it
but why should we let this villain take
a public playground just because it
wasn't Central Park and and we
eventually meet him you also were an
original member of the mayor's Institute
on City design for the National
Endowment for the Arts right what's that
it's a it's a wonderful thing put
together by Adele chatfield Taylor which
has conferences every year and gets
design experts in different fields and
mayor's from different cities for a long
weekend and each gives presentations the
mayor's in their cities and the experts
on different issues affecting America so
that they can learn from each other
about it about all the issues including
transportation or parking or just urban
beautification or whatever of urban
design your book is endorsed by at least
three people for people Andrew Tobias
who is he he is a columnist for Time
magazine and also a an author in his own
right I don't know him so you had
nothing to do with the endorsement it's
endorsed by Andrew a high school former
publisher of times right yeah I'm
acquainted with him we're not I mean
we're I know him too casely have dinner
with the death of common sense is a
wildly important book which should
change the direction of public debate in
this country I think it has not yet but
it's striking a chord I've just gone
down to Florida to visit the governor
who's invited me down to talk about
ideas for remaking his government around
the ideas in my book and several other
governors have also called
so I'm I'm hopeful that it may make a
difference it's endorsed by Arthur
Schlesinger he said God started all this
one right he was very helpful to me
through the process and was a sounding
board he kept urging me to go get more
history a brilliant diagnosis forceful
trenchant and eloquent what's it take to
get an endorsement from Professor
slicing you like that I don't know he
read the book it offered it up and then
the other one is John I'm not sure it
pronounces gear rare guerre right i know
john g ua r e and who is he John's a
friend he's he is a playwright and and a
very brilliant a thoughtful person he
wrote six degrees of separation the
movie Atlantic City house of blue leaves
a number of lots of lots of plays and
some movies and how much of a say-so do
you have in the title and the cover and
your picture and these endorsements um
well I cared about the cover so I had
say so I care about things like that I
had the photograph taken tried to make
myself look as good as possible why the
death of common sense i mean when did
you recognize that as the title well you
know it's the about halfway through the
writing of it it's what i'm writing
about what we've done is create a system
of law that that doesn't allow people to
use their judgment mean in bureaucracy
the entire ethic is that you're not
supposed to use your judgment a few
years ago there was a leak and IM it in
an abandoned railroad tunnel underneath
the chicago river and because the leak
could be potentially disastrous it
immediately got up to the top levels you
know whether with the commissioner and
the commissioner said we better fix this
up right away how much is it going to
cost his assistant so I think it'll cost
about ten thousand dollars so they were
going to go to a reputable contractor
and get it fixed guy came back the next
day and said well they say it's going to
cost seventy-five thousand dollars at
that point the Commissioner paused and
said well that's you know it someone
might criticize me or you know for spin
to that kind of discrepancy
so you better put it out for competitive
bids because that's the way things are
done in government which I mean that
takes months or years depending on which
comfortably talking about before the
process even got going the tunnel
collapsed the water flowed into every
basement in downtown Chicago cost a
billion and a half dollars worth of
damage knows it all the files turn into
wet pulp computers were ruined
short-circuiting you know electrical
boxes everywhere was complete nightmare
it stopped downtown Chicago because the
head bureaucrat of a major agency didn't
want to take the responsibility for
spending seventy-five thousand dollars
to fix that leak and the interesting
thing about it is you can understand
because in our current culture we so
criticize people for doing anything for
taking responsibility that you can see
some tabloid saying gee he spent seventy
five thousand dollars he's done business
with him before let's investigate if
there's so much distrust in the system
that no one everyone's a fool it would
be a fool to use their judgment so they
don't it's a hole we've created an
entire legal system in furtherance of
the idea that human judgment has no
place in law when law as a human
institution law can't think it will
never be able to think words on a page
will never be able to tell a bureaucrat
or us or anyone else how to do the right
thing when did you know that you had
something here that people were going to
pay more than passing attention to what
was the first indication I thought even
before I decided to write the book that
I that the ID I'd come up I thought I'd
discovered something that was really
important give it when it was it that
you got confirmation somebody said I
want to excerpt that or I want you to
come on my show or whatever you know I
didn't need that with all due respect I
really thought I knew I had it I know I
had it before I wrote it I don't mean
that you didn't know I just mean when
did you first get that real indication
random house when they saw the
manuscript quadruple
estimated size of the first printing
would you print first what I don't know
i think there's about 60,000 copies okay
that was the first indication then when
did you have the first public
confirmation in other words that first
endorsement where somebody says you've
got to do my show or somebody wrote a
column about it well I sent the
manuscript around two to a few people
like Andrew high school Andrew high
school is not a person given to too
effusive language and he called me up
and he any pause and said hello this is
mrs. Andrew high school I've read your
manuscript thank you he paused again he
said this is a wildly important book it
will change America and I'll do whatever
I can to promote it you've got what I'm
getting at is here you got Arthur
Schlesinger on this flap and you've got
George will on the other side doing the
same thing in his column so what is it
that no one wants to take the blame or
no one wants to take the credit for what
happened over the last 30 years I don't
think it who cares what the blame where
the credit is the question is what the
question is what works and and it's
understandable how we got here the
system is plausible it just doesn't
happen to work and I think what I've
tried to do as I said is is create a
different way of looking at it it's as
if I put on a new pair of glasses and
said hey wait a minute if you look at
this public goal and these goals this
way if you scrapped the assumption that
everything must be exactly the same I
mean there's all of law we have this
idea of uniformity that really is the
central planning everything must be the
same all is perfect decisions come out
prepackaged fresh frozen untouched by
human hands that's what law is you'll
get the system we have which is nothing
but red tape and ineffectiveness and and
all I've done is take away the
underpinnings that have generated all
this red tape and ineffectiveness and I
think both the right and the left see it
for the truth of it okay then how then
you change it
well first you give them the vocabulary
for changing it which they haven't had
before which I hope that my book does or
give an example too easy Carol Browner
epa administrator who I know it's driven
crazy by exactly the things I'm talking
about in the book she says okay what do
we need to get authorization what change
in legislation to negotiate pollution
control plans with major factories what
do we need to do that what do we need to
be able to make exceptions or or to just
disregard for the moment all these rules
and regulations she figures out what
that is at the worst it's a five lines
and a statute passed by Congress and
then she says let's go up or she says
come on in you don't like your pollution
control plan let's negotiate and all of
a sudden I think what you would find in
those negotiation which would be complex
because these things are complicated
issues is that you could probably reduce
pollution dramatically and in most cases
probably reduce costs dramatically
because you could customize it and
factories is a huge chemical complexes
or the like are too complicated you
can't do that with every tannery you've
got to have a different set of rules for
that they're not enough people but you
can for the five thousand plants that
produce ninety-five percent of the
stationary pollution of this country let
me read for five lines here something
you wrote 30 years ago with the Civil
Rights Act of 1964 our country passed a
landmark law that succeeded in breakdown
in breaking down many artificial
barriers the law did not eliminate
prejudice but it created an opportunity
in which prejudice could begin to
dissipate now barely three decades later
we are well on our way to rebuilding
those animosities discrimination is an
open wound of our society but like
animals instead of caring for it as it
heals slowly we can't help but keep
biting at it the wound just opens up
more alright
30 years later the Civil Rights Act
didn't work it worked it did work
actually worked on its own terms we
broke down barriers of desegregation
what it's doing now though is actually
counterproductive and this is an
incredibly interesting and perhaps the
most dangerous and subtle point of the
points in the book because there you had
a situation where people did not enjoy
the freedoms that that the rest of the
Americans enjoyed it and so for
examination against for centuries women
had been discriminated against for
millennia so we had these laws passed
that were very effective not in
eliminating prejudice but eliminating
the sort of the institutional barriers
that existed but what's happened now is
that now that those those barriers are
down not that prejudice is eliminated
but the basic institutional barriers are
down is discrimination law is being used
in a completely different way it's
become the language of workplace
discrimination so instead of going after
some company that never promoted women
because they were women now what it is
is it's used by people who have a fight
because they lose their job or they
don't get a promotion and they say that
was discrimination and my point is that
becomes something goes from something
that you can look at and identify a
pattern or practice of discrimination to
something that no one can possibly know
which is what is in someone else's soul
and the result is that nobody in America
the country of the First Amendment no
longer appreciates no longer tolerates
candor people don't say what they think
because it might be used against them in
a discrimination claim it's perfectly
counterproductive business businesses
don't take chances on minorities because
particularly one who may not have the
educational qualifications that others
might have because you're afraid they'll
never be able to get rid of them you
know it's a it's a it's it's reduced its
employers patronize blacks who don't
need to be patronized at all
and it's it's created a rift a
communication rift which will make it
impossible for us ever to be an
integrated society because people are no
longer talking of all the people you
spent time with and we named a lot of
Hughes and Brennan and Warren and
frankfurter and Scalia and Wilson and
Webster Daniel Webb straight and
mentioned earlier in Landis and Madison
and rice in a hovel in vapor and Hayek
and Tocqueville who would you recommend
if someone wasn't for mayor as you are
with all this that they go out and pull
the book off the shelf and spend some
time with I think that the I think I
would read Cardozo's the nature of the
judicial process which is still
available in paperback I would read
Posner's compendium of homes as writing
this is richard posner from chicago yes
Richard Posner's a judge the judge I
would read I don't think I would read
Landis or Hayek license or go on too
long Havel is brilliant on the subject
boss of hobble understands how
anti-human Western democratic structures
have become and every year or so he'll
write an op-ed article warning us
against the effects of rationalism the
idea that we can figure everything out
in advance and lay it out in a
government structure and in a law hovel
is hovel is wonderful in the subject
here's what the book looks like it's
called the death of common sense and our
guest is Phillip K Howard we thank you
very much for joining us thank you